thank you for joining me on et Canada
Prai thank you for having me how does it
feel to be back home it's always so nice
to be back in Canada it's like a nice
little visit to myself when I was living
here what do you miss most about living
here is there something you miss about
Canada the accessibility to room
temperature cheese curds is definitely
one of gas stations I definitely missed
that I miss I miss like a good sugar pie
or a tough to a stable dahab
[Music]
congratulations on a third season of the
show thank you wow I can't believe that
three seasons have been out already it's
an eight year and this is e.t.c pride so
just having that representation out
there it means so much to so many people
how does it feel for you to have so many
people receiving the show so well and
being a representative of the lgbtq+
community I still get a little bit of
like a bead of sweat that forms down my
back when you say representative of
anything because I still feel like I'm
trying to figure myself out and who I am
but I try to take it with as much
humility as I can and I'm still learning
like the more appearances that I do or
the more things that I get involved in I
get a lot of feedback from people and I
really am just figuring it out as I go
but I am very cognizant and aware of the
fact that all eyes are on me so I just
try to basically not be it by giving
them a little bit of care by giving them
love and attention and some affection it
makes people feel worthy be a good
person and be curious and always ask
questions and like find the things that
you want to like learn more about and if
you don't know about something don't
pretend like you do yeah go ahead and
ask those questions and that's something
that the show has taught me as well it's
like if you look at season two with
Skylar I just want to be able to be
visible and be present and let everybody
know that I'm okay
we had our first trans person and tan
and I knew the least out of the five of
us in terms of like our experience with
trans people and sort of like everything
that that entails and so we decided like
okay we're gonna go and we're gonna be
honest about it and be like I don't mean
to offend you but I don't know a lot
about this whole thing can you like
teach me it's a two sided street that's
so important and that's what every
single hero it's not just us imparting
our wisdom or knowledge or whatever it
is that we want to throw their way but
it's like you have to be willing to like
take in that information
learn as well and just keep the
conversation going yeah it's like you
just said like I may be doing a eg
Canada pride but I'm still learning
every single day when I speak right well
you know it's just educating each other
educating the community
you got gave us tools to work with chill
dude we didn't have but now we have them
I do have a video message from one of
your co-stars I would like to show you
I'm not gonna tell you who it is because
I will kill the surprise I do like
surprises okay what do people not know
about aunt ha obviously they know he's
good-looking you're gorgeous
he gets embarrassed every time I do the
most when people tell you they're
good-looking he always is like uh I just
got a mess what else oh you know
something that people don't know is that
he is one of the most exceptional actors
ever oh go back in the footage there is
roles where he was acting I have
predicted and I told him this and he
gets embarrassed that he will win an
Academy Award
Johnny Boz she becomes subscribe stage
vesko
Jackie yes so I want you to tell me
something about Karami that people may
not know he can fall asleep standing up
and not even twitch like when I fall
asleep I do like the really I do like
the head bobbing like the drool coming
out of my mouth situation with him he'll
stay perfectly still and like really Zen
and then the director will come in and
be like okay we're ready to go and then
he will just open his eyes and be like
alright let's continue but he'll be full
asleep and sometimes if you just listen
ever so slightly and I'm sure the sound
people can hear this you can hear like a
really gentle snoring like that and he's
full of sleep it's not even just eyes
closed he's asleep it's terrified
there's I don't know if he's gonna be in
like medical textbooks for this cuz it's
yeah it's really impressive perfect
queer I came into my lap and it was this
like beautiful gift that I didn't even
know I needed or wanted
Oh the main lesson from queer eye is
been when you have work that's
meaningful where you get to impact
somebody else's life
that's a new bar for me I have to do
things that are personal that I'm
passionate about things that are
actually really interesting to me in
every facet of everything that I do so
when I do go back into it I will say
when this why the hell not and I kind of
have to I know that I want to go in with
that with that same intention that I
kind of brings her queer I thanks for
hanging with me I look forward to seeing
you in Phil's and these are gorgeous
they're really really are beautiful